[Musik]
so von Tag ein Scouting direkt ins
nächste Drama
ja ein Thema ein unschönes Thema haben
wir auch noch es gab den ersten Einsatz
ich sag mal so das was dort passiert ist
würde ich jetzt mal als leise sagen ist
schon mal eine Nummer schlimmer als das
schlimmste aus Staffel 1
in der letzten Folge habt ihr erfahren
aus welchen vier Personen das Medical
Team besteht in dieser Folge möchten wir
euch einen tieferen Einblick geben
welche Vorbereitungen mussten getroffen
werden wie weit reichen unsere
Behandlungsmöglichkeiten vor Ort und was
passiert wenn diese nicht mehr
ausreichen wie ist das Team ausgestattet
und wie agiert es in einem echten
Notfall viel Spaß mit Folge 6 von
sevenvers White behind the scenes
die heutige Folge wird unterstützt von
Koro bei denen ihr dauerhaft mit dem
Code Dave 5% aufs gesamte Sortiment
sparen könnt von Snacks wie diesen
gefriergetrockneten Himbeeren im
Schokoladenmantel über Nussmischung bis
hin zu regeln ist so ziemlich alles ans
nächster dabei was ihr für einen
perfekten seven vor dem Fernseher
braucht außerdem gibt es eine Menge
Zutaten zum Kochen und Backen und das
Beste auf Fähre und nachhaltige
Produktion wir im Büro nutzen fast jeden
Morgen das porrekt von Trockenfrüchten
um gut gestärkt für euch diese Videos
schneiden zu können klickt jetzt auf den
ersten Link in der Videobeschreibung
bestellt euch eure Snacks und spart
dauerhaft mit dem Code Dave 5 % auf
gesamte Sortiment vielen Dank für die
Unterstützung und euch viel Spaß mit dem
Video ein ich bin Island Julia äh ich
bin Nordharz
in einer maximalversorge bei der
Gefäßchirurgie gehen ich bin hier für
medizinische Versorgung zuständig okay
moin ich bin Thorsten ich studiere
Mediziner und arbeite bei wandern gut
dort bin ich für die gesamte Auto
verantwortlich und nebenbei arbeite ich
auch als Auto der Erste Hilfe Ausbilder
ja unsere medical-demo ist viel Leute
groß dazu gehöre ich natürlich Thorsten
Clemens und noch Björn der diese
erfahrene Notfallsanitäter haben wir
auch im Rettungsdienstbereich lange mit
dem gearbeitet ich kenne sein Arbeit des
professioneller Mann Clemens haben wir
hier erstmal kennengelernt der ist
Feuermann dabei auch Rettungssanitäter
der ist auch aktiv beschäftigt mm Sektor
ja ich glaube jeder hat seine seine
besondere Funktion also Islam natürlich
ist halt unser Notarzt der geht nichts
drüber und sowas braucht man natürlich
auch für so ein Projekt am Clemens z.B
ist allzeit bereit so völlig scheißegal
ob nachts am Tag so Clemens rennt und
rettet die Welt so Björn so ist unser
guter ruhepulver haben ja auch
tatsächlich in Deutschland schon lange
Zeit zusammen gearbeitet dementsprechend
haben die auch wirklich nahtloses
Teamwork ja und meine Wenigkeit hat dann
halt im Endeffekt den deutschen
Rettungsdienst auf die Isar sandrose
nach Panama gebracht
ja also wir waren zum Zeitpunkt des
Geschehens gerade eben dabei unser
ganzes Equipment zu organisieren dann
kam der Tom reinmarschiert von
wandermute war so mein Gott Notfall
Notfall Johannes blutet Schnittwunde
action
ja dann kam ein wirklicher Schwein von
Leuten in dieses Zimmer unsere gesamte
Ordnung die werden dem Moment
eingerichtet hatten war dahin und ja es
wird die erste Panik ein bisschen runter
gespielt hatten hat sich das Islam
erstmal angeguckt
also wir haben gerade unten versucht die
Gegenstände also Fotos zu machen und
dann ist abgetrieben dann sind
Zufall habe ich sie dann gesehen und
dann habe ich gegriffen
jetzt habe ich auf dem Knochen aber
erster Praxistest fürs Medizin jo jetzt
machen
so bleiben
[Musik]
man könnte keine Fremdkörper sehen was
ganz wichtig ist bei Premiere dass man
fremd war alles rausholt die wunder
schön ausspült und desinfiziert und dann
je nach Tiefe gibt bestimmte Technik der
Wundverschluss haben wir uns angeguckt
und dann Tor hat der Mega Bock zu nähen
hat er angefangen zu machen
also medical team auch bevor die
Teilnehmer angekommen sind den Test
bestanden Operationen hier in der Base
möglich alles wunderbar alles dabei
alles funktioniert Finger und weitere
Dinge können genäht werden alles bestens
Abkühlung nach Desinfektionsmittel im
stillen Umgebung hat er angefangen
Wunder zuzunehmen haben wir auch
vorgesessen vorgesehen haben werde ich
glaube
auch entfernt wurde sieht soweit gut aus
ist top
was soll ich sagen ne ich habe es
verdient auch bisschen
Johannes Verletzung war zum Glück kein
Code Red doch was wenn es wirklich zu
einer ernsten Verletzung kommt genau
deswegen haben Paddy Thorsten und Islam
ein passendes Sicherheitskonzept
ausgearbeitet weil Sicherheitskonzept
ist die Sache du schaust immer wie
kannst du die Gefahren so weit wie
möglich reduzieren also ganz realistisch
ist es unmöglich irgendwelche Gefahren
komplett zu vermeiden dafür müsste man
in Deutschland bleiben irgendwo in
seinem Wohnzimmer und die Füße hochlegen
das geht nicht das ist unrealistisch ein
bisschen das Risiko bleibt immer aber
wenn du ein paar Maßnahmen präventiv
triffst und wenn du eine starke
Rettungskette auf die Beine stellst
kannst du zumindest die
Wahrscheinlichkeit denken dass nur von
Eintritt und wenn es doch passiert dass
die Personen mit schweren Schäden
rauskommt haben wir sehr gute Kontakte
zu Militär der Tom kannte den Baum der
ist Spiel sicherheitsabläufe bei der
Bundeswehr zuständig er hat uns mit dem
Konzept versorgt was er selber
entwickelt hat oder mit der Struktur die
bei der Bundeswehr vorgehen und das
heißt was machst du du schaust erstmal
die Umgebung an die Insel du schaust wie
sind die klimatischen Bedingungen welche
Gefahren gibt es durch die Umwelt und
was du dann machst ist du gehst diese
Reise des Teilnehmers gehst du Schritt
für Schritt durch also du fängst an mit
dem Helikopter Dropper auf dann das an
Land schwimmen dann Shelter bauen Feuer
machen Essen und Trinken suchen und du
guckst bei jeder dieser Station okay wo
kann überall was schief gehen ne also du
meinst sie wirklich die krassesten
Horrorszenarien aus und dann hast du am
Ende eine riesige Liste von allem was du
daneben gehen kannst und dann schaust du
dir die verschiedenen Gefahren an und du
ermittel ist ein Risiko Kennzahlen
oftmals wird man ja denken über heilen
Griff jeder hat Jones gesehen jeder hält
das für die krasseste Gefahr ist aber
überhaupt nicht die Gefahr die uns am
meisten Sorgen gemacht hat und das liegt
dann dieser Herangehensweise oder diese
Betrachtung durch die Risiko Kennzahl
wie sie aufgebaut du hast einmal die
Schwere der Gefahr also was wie schwer
ist der Schaden wenn wenn der Eintritt
beim Hai maximal das ist tödlich dann
hast du aber auf der anderen Seite noch
die Wahrscheinlichkeit wie
wahrscheinlich tritt das auf und du
hattest zum Beispiel in den perleninseln
einen tödlichen Haiangriff in den
letzten 100 Jahren das heißt die
Wahrscheinlichkeit ist sehr niedrig und
dann hast du eine mittlere Risiko
Kennzahl du hast andere Gefahren zum
Beispiel mit der Machete dreimal am Tag
eine Palme hochklettern während dem
Felsen sind die sind deutlich höher
einzustufen in der Risiko Kennzahl als
ebenso eine kraftlinge Gefahr wie z.B
ein Angriff durch ein Hai oder Krokodil
jetzt rechts aber nicht wenn du Aldi
Gefahren ermittelt hast das ist Nico das
heißt du musst auch noch Maßnahmen dann
dafür entwickeln nehmen wir jetzt
irgendein Beispiel sagen wir mal fritz
hat sich mit der Machete ins Bein also
unwahrscheinlich zum einen kann mit der
Machete umgehen zu machen
[Gelächter]
mit Spaß jemand nochmal fit bekommen ja
aber angenommen so etwas passiert wir
haben identifiziert okay gut das hatten
relativ hohe Risiko Kennzahl das einer
der Teilnehmer sich mit der Machete
verletzt dann fragen wir uns zwei Sachen
ja was können wir tun um diese
Wahrscheinlichkeit zu reduzieren da
kannst du zum Beispiel Briefing machen
das erklärt okay mit der Machete immer
vom Körper weg hatten dass wir einen
turnicky in die Teilnehmer Kids packen
damit sie sich im Notfall selber
versorgen können und dann fragst du was
kannst du machen wenn ja wenn die Kacke
am Dampfen ist okay wenn so etwas
passiert wir haben einen Helikopter auf
der Insel wir haben insgesamt vier
Medics und wir haben die Möglichkeit mit
dem Helikopter wirklich in unter einer
halben Stunde zum Patienten zu kommen
also besser weil ist sage ich mal das
probierst dieses wahnsinnig wahnsinnig
kompliziert weil die Leute sind
natürlich allein für sich es gibt dieses
totmannsystem aber wir haben eigentlich
in der Zentrale relativ wenig Überblick
aber der für den Fall dass ein Notfall
passiert sind die Leute für eine halbe
Stunde Minimum auf sich allein gestellt
um da erstmal zu agieren und
dementsprechend ist es natürlich
wahnsinnig wichtig dass Sie Prävention
also dass sie einfach Maßnahmen
selbstständig durchführen können erstmal
erkennen und dann durchführen können für
die erkennen haben wir den briefumgehalt
vielen Informationen gegeben wo die
allein nie drauf gekommen hätten aber
nach dem Briefen könnte man merken die
haben immer noch Angst weil die viele
Informationen auf einmal bekommen haben
aber danach im Spätabend könnte man die
Entspannung schon merken wie die
entspannter sind weil die wissen wenn da
gebissen wird was wird gemacht wenn da
irgendwie Hitzeschlag kommt was wird
gemacht und die Prozess haben die mehr
strukturierte genau das ist glaub das
auch wahnsinnig wichtig so eine
Selbstwirksamkeit zu haben weil ich
meine jeder kennt das ja von sich selber
wenn irgendwas passiert man hat
überhaupt gar keine Ahnung was man
machen soll genauso breitet sich
maximale Panik aus und alles scheiße so
aber selbst wenn man nicht genau weiß
man hat so ein bisschen Ahnung das hilft
einem schon wahnsinnig viel weiter vor
allen Dingen auch über diese Panik
drüber weg zu kommen und einfach zu
sagen okay ich kann hier eigentlich was
machen und ich bin nicht komplett am
Arsch und das war auch für so ein
Projekt einfach unglaublich essentiell
weil wir sind nun mal eine Weile weg die
sind nun mal sehr für sich da muss sowas
halt im Vorfeld auch geklärt sein bevor
die Teilnehmer auf die Insel
rausgelassen wurden haben die natürlich
von uns auch noch Briefing bekommen wie
sie sich in verschiedenen Situationen
primär zu verhalten haben
sehr gut das ist so dass ich auch in
Deutschland dafür Kurse gebe zusammen
mit Märten aber mein Kollegen haben wir
jetzt auch einen neuen Autor Erste Hilfe
Kurs eigentlich entwickelt und ja die
Links dafür findet ihr unten in der
Videobeschreibung check das gerne aus
wir freuen uns total wenn ihr mal vorbei
schaut und es ist tatsächlich bis jetzt
relativ einzigartig weil in Deutschland
gibt es wenig Angebot und vor allen
Dingen wenig fundiert ist Angebot und da
haben wir halt gedacht okay für alle
begeisterten und für Projekte wie dieses
bietet sie sich natürlich an da einfach
besser informiert und besser für den
Notfall vorbereitet zu sein muss ich als
Notfallmediziner auch sagen ich habe
sogar vom Thorsten vieles gelernt der
hat mega geile Tipps was meine in
zinnbereich alltäglich
Notfallmedizin nicht sieht oder damit
Kontakt hat beim survivalbereich habe
ich von Thorsten vieles gelernt ich
würde auch empfehlen also es gibt zwei
Erste Hilfe Kids das eine das muss
ständig am Mann getragen werden das ist
das schwarze das ist das sogenannte 60
Sekunden Kit das ist offensichtlich
selbst erklärend worum es so heißt da
geht es um die Wurst und dann muss
schnell handeln da ist im Endeffekt ein
Tor nicht gehe außen dran für eine
schnelle Blutstillung von der
sogenannten Mutter aller Blutungen also
wirklich eine riesengroßen atelen
springbrunnenhaften Blutungen die man
haben kann weil das geht wirklich sehr
sehr schnell bis man da nichts mehr tun
kann dann ist da drins und zwei
Medikamente um den allergischen Schock
zumindest erstmal unter Kontrolle zu
bekommen bis wir da sind gleichzeitig
Kühlkompresse für den Fall dass sage ich
mal irgendwie der heißt zu spät dass man
da noch ein bisschen kühlen kann und die
Atemwege nicht zu sichern aber zumindest
erstmal zu dämpfen genau und dann haben
wir dann noch eine grüne elastische bin
drin ich meine es ist zwar so
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ein giftiges Tier
auf dieser Insel zu treffen sehr gering
bis ausgeschlossen ist aber
ausgeschlossen kann man halt sagen und
für den Fall dass man doch von etwas
gebissen ist von dem man dann ausgeht
dass es giftig ist kann man einen ein
leichten wie so eine Art Stützverband
anlegen und das schindet wahnsinnig viel
Zeit das ist im 60 Sekunden Kit das
andere das ist das grüne First Aid Kit
das ist primär zur Wundversorgung da da
ist es je nach Kenntnisstand der
Teilnehmer tatsächlich so dass man mit
einem Druckverband tatsächlich auch
größere Wunden erstmal Blut stellen kann
genau versorgen kann und ja halt auch
dann weiter die Wundversorgung machen
kann dazu gehört und Spülung ich denke
Kontrolle komplett Material was man
braucht sogar antiseptische Salbe haben
wir ein antibiotische Salbe haben wir da
drin dass er langfristig wenn die
Teilnehmer z.B erste Seite sich
verletzen nicht dafür rauskommen sondern
sich selber versorgen dass die neuen
sicheren Bereich sind und wenn die halt
nicht zurechtkommen wir sind 24 Stunde 7
Tage dabei jederzeit rufbereit könnte
mir jederzeit dir so kann man sagen mehr
Unterstützung extrem wichtiger Tag heute
fürs gesamte Orga-Team heute wird das
erste Mal die Rettung und Aussetzung von
Leuten getestet also der Heli wird über
die Insel fliegen wir werden an einem
Spot einmal das komplette
rettungsszenario testen alle sind ein
bisschen angespannt keiner weiß so
richtig was auf uns zukommt obwohl alles
unheimlich gut durchgeplant ist sind
genau solche Proben natürlich mega
wichtig ein Teil vom Team fährt mit dem
Boot los der andere Teil vom Team fliegt
eine Helikopter von Panama City aus also
jetzt geht's richtig ab so zurück im
Hangar wir machen einen Szenario in dem
Tom also tut als wäre er Unglück beim
Absprung und wird dann von Martin
unserem Rettungsschwimmer gerettet ja
danach werden wir noch auf der
panamaklinik landen um zu gucken wie es
wäre wenn wir dann die Verwundeten auch
jetzt im Krankenhaus fahren würden also
könntet
was erwartest du vom Tag ich hoffe dass
wir unsere Rettungskette vernünftig
erproben können und dann mit einem guten
Gewissen ins Projekt starten können ich
hoffe einfach nur das so schnell genug
da sind weil der Helikopter ist echt
verdammt schnell vom Panama City aus
hier und wir haben ordentliches Stück
mit dem Boot zurückzulegen
war nicht nur eine Notfallübung für den
Job auf sondern wir haben einmal die
komplette Flugroute die wir vorher
geplant haben über die Insel mit den
einzelnen Koordinaten sind wir
abgeflogen in der Reihenfolge wie die
Teilnehmer dann ausgesetzt werden
sollten um einfach zu gucken klappt das
in der Kommunikation zwischen uns den
Koordinatoren und den Piloten fliegt der
zu den richtigen Stränden weiß ja
natürlich eine absolute Katastrophe wenn
wenn Leute vertauschen würde etc das
mussten einfach testen und der grüne
Abschluss war dann eben die Übung mit
dem Ertrinkenden Teilnehmer der dann
durch den Rettungsschwimmer gerettet
werden musste
so der Plan ist jetzt wir sitzen
Helikopter befinden uns an Joris Spot
und machen hier ein testsprung draußen
ist das Rettungsboot es ist schon bereit
damit auch die Medics hier im Einsatz
einmal testen können ich werde ins
Wasser springen ich heiße ungeübten
Schwimmer in Panik versetzen
mit kurzer Verzögerung sprang Martin
hinterher um den in Panik geratenen
Tomaten
[Musik]
dann folgt ihr das medical team um die
wichtigsten lebenssichernden Maßnahmen
zu treffen bei der wirklichen Aussetzung
der Teilnehmer war das medical team mit
dem Helikopter das war eine Übung leider
nicht für uns zu simulieren
[Musik]
wahnsinnig schwer gemacht gerade
erstens ganz klarer Fall Stiefel beim
drop off müssen aus ich glaube ich werde
sogar das T-Shirt war ausziehen müssen
weil das ist alles Widerstand im Wasser
und ja ich wäre schon dass ich krass
ausgelaufen bin aber das war eine
exzellente Übung auch noch mal zu sehen
wo ich technisch noch etwas besser
machen kann und ähm wo wir auf jeden
Fall auch jetzt Verbesserungen gesehen
haben die wir beim nächsten Mal besser
machen ja
absolute über Knaller so sollte man
jeden Tag tun so also wirklich hat sich
angefühlt wie so ein Drop so aber alle
anderen gesagt sehr cool aus dann nehme
ich das und ähm mann das war eine geile
experience tom ist wirklich schwer ich
glaube jeder ist wirklich schwer also
Leute mal kurz einen Strand hochtragen
sie wirklich einfach aus als es ist ja
dann war das Rettungsteam da so wir
haben gut gemacht und zwar der Hammer so
so vor soweit nicht in Ordnung sondern
mehr als in Ordnung aber perfekt wir
haben schnell beim Patienten konnten gut
arbeiten Patient wurde gerettet Ziel
erfüllt
das ganze Team war die Übung also ein
voller Erfolg und wir wussten dass wir
die Teilnehmer guten Gewissens aus dem
Heli werfen konnten nur einem war nicht
ganz nach Feiern zumute
wir sind jetzt gerade mit dem Heli
gelandet
hier an den nächsten Strand bei unserer
testübung
also ich weiß ja ansieht
ist so kotzübel das ist wirklich
also das hatte ich selten was natürlich
schlecht weil ich der Kameramann bin in
der neben Heli also wenn ich da dem
Piloten die Armatur vollkotze ist das
auch nicht die beste Variante
[Musik]
an diesem Tag kommt er das Team leider
nicht auf dem Krankenhaus nach landen im
Notfall würde dies aber möglich sein
musste nur vier
beendet auf helipet konnten wir leider
nicht landen vom Krankenhaus weil wir
wir was keine Frage bekommen haben so
kurzfristig ansonsten sind uns auf jeden
Fall noch ein paar Fehler aufgefallen
die wir jetzt danach Besprechung
abklären müssen also sehr gut dass wir
es gemacht haben ich habe sehr viel
kalten Schweiß verloren aber ein
bisschen witzig auch
spaßig würde ich nicht sagen für mich
zumindest nicht und während dem einen
kotzübel war schnitt sich der andere mit
der Drohne in den Finger und das medical
team musste sofort wieder an die Arbeit
was für eine unglaubliche
testrettungsaktion alles dabei und jetzt
sogar noch ein richtiger Einsatz max hat
sich beim Drohne fangen in die Finger
geschnitten und muss jetzt tatsächlich
erst versorgt werden
[Musik]
wie Party das ja bestimmt auch schon
erzählt hat so gibt es das Dreifache
Code Systems und Ampelsystem bei uns
Code Green ist das was die Teilnehmer
und abends Absenden muss ich einfach
sagen hier ist alles gut so der
Dschungel lebt wir leben auch Coach
yellow ist im Endeffekt entweder so holt
mich hier raus so oder
nicht kritische Verletzung die einfach
Zeit hat und Code Red ist da wo es
wirklich um die Uhr also muss schnell
gehen muss ohne kritische Verletzung da
ist wo es um Leben und Tod letzten Endes
geht und der Grund warum bei einem Code
yellow hauptsächlich Clemens und ich
rausfahren ist das für den Fall dass in
dem Moment noch ein zweiter Notfall
passiert der potentiell viel schlimmer
ist als sage ich mal eine banale
Abholung oder eine kleine Verletzung ist
das Islam jederzeit verfügbar ist mit
Björn zusammen dann diesen Notfall auch
zu bearbeiten wir kontrollieren trotzdem
jeder Code Rede auch koordinao bevor wir
losfahren weil jeder kann in 15 Sekunden
kann auch kondreht sein sollte es
allerdings mal so sein dass wir sagen
okay das können wir so nicht handeln
kommt der Patient dann in der Regel zum
Hel Adapter und wird dann in Begleitung
mit Islam und Björn nach Panama City
geflogen dort haben wir mit der
panamaklinik tatsächlich schon Kontakt
gehabt wir haben oben in Helipad da wird
drauf gelandet und dann geht das weiter
wie ganz normalem Deutschland um diese
maximale Sicherheit zu gewährleisten
haben wir dann bei uns im Camp jeden Tag
Code Red war bei uns in Notfall haben
wir das einfach eingeübt im Team um
dieses System zu testen wurde der
Ernstfall mehrmals in den Tagen vor
Ankunft und sogar nach der Aussetzung
der Teilnehmer kontinuierlich geprobt
ziel war es das bei einer realen
Notfallsituation nicht nur jedes Team
Mitglied genau wusste was seine Aufgabe
war sondern wir wirklich veränderlich
hatten wie wir zu handeln haben
guter Training ich habe kein Zeitgefühl
wie viel wir gebraucht haben aber ich
glaube bis jetzt alles strukturiert
gelaufen wäre dann gleich Übersprechen
verbessern ins Wasser haben wenn der
kommt wenn Du beispielsweise eintreffen
würde also eine sofortige Rettungsaktion
mit all unseren Mitteln von Nöten wäre
geht erst Alarm geschlagen
Islam als Notarzt übernimmt das
Satellitentelefon sofern ein Kontakt
über Satellitentelefon möglich ist um
eine erste Einschätzung über den Notfall
zu bekommen
im Anschluss fliegen Notarzt und
Notfallsanitäter mit dem Heli auf
schnellstem Wege zum Patienten
Rettungssanitäter und rettungsassistenz
folgen diesen dann zu Unterstützung mit
einem Boot
Fazit Perry sehr geil nachdem es am
ersten Tag bei der Übung noch ein
ziemlich wildes Chaos war jeder Rand
hier rum es war super hektisch ist
inzwischen erstaunlich lernen der
Zentrale das liegt daran dass alle genau
wissen was sie zu tun haben jeder weiß
wer zum Beispiel den Helikopter Piloten
alarmieren soll oder im Bootsfahrer ist
noch heute alles reibungslos geklappt
stimmt nicht guter Dinge tatsächlich ein
Fall passiert gestern aber noch gesehen
okay diese letzten kleinen
Stellschrauben hier mit dem Boot gab es
noch ein bisschen Probleme und heute es
war absolut perfekt
ja alles klar das ist eine fantastische
Zeit habe richtig gut aus Leute Ablauf
ach ja und durch den dummen Fehler sind
in der letzten Folge zwei super wichtige
Teammitglieder nicht von mir aufgezählt
worden der mir und Malina sind für den
gesamten social media content abseits
von Youtube verantwortlich haben mit
organisiert und das Team vor Ort in so
ziemlich jedem Punkt unterstützt hier
also noch mal ein besonderes Danke an
euch beide und gleichzeitig sorry von
mir das hat dir schon dieses Gefühl von
Sicherheit gegeben okay wenn ihr
wirklich was passiert dann sofort wird
da dieses ist während des Ziehens
parallel zur Hauptserie veröffentlicht
wird und wir natürlich nichts
vorwegnehmen wollen werden ab sofort
immer nur freitags neue Folgen kommen
vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren
um das nicht zu verpassen
[Musik]